the process gets started Chris with the
Cincinnati Bengals on the clock look I
still can't completely and totally rule
out Stephen Ross taking over the
Dolphins draft room and making the
Bengals an offer they can't and won't
refuse but it looks like it's going to
be Joe borough - the Cincinnati Bengals
with the first overall pick in the draft
do you see any scenario where that does
not happen no I do not you know I don't
you know first off I mean you know Joe
burrow like I told you Mike when we
talked about quarterbacks it's almost a
flawless film study I mean he's so
talented and for a national football
championship team okay there pass
protection stunk at LSU I mean you watch
Joe burrow on film and you just go he's
under duress every play every other play
and he just makes so many frickin plays
within the pocket not only scrambling
but just moving people around him make
him big-time throws Mike and the one
thing I've consistently heard you know
from around the NFL people are they're
totally impressed with Joe Burrell the
man the leader you know the guy he has
the charisma everything about it so III
don't see there's any way and I've been
told by a few people in the know already
that the bangles are just smitten with
what they've learned and with what
they've gotten to know about Joe Burrell
here through this process I'm gonna be
talking to him this afternoon and one of
the things I want to really delve into
how he handled that period of time at
Ohio State when he was passed over for
Dwayne Hoskins the decision to transfer
he graduated from Ohio State in three
years my goodness that's what allowed
him to play right away at LSU in 2018
and not have to take a year off but you
know we see the finished product we see
the guy who's ready to be the number one
overall pick in the draft and we just
assumed it was easy for him every step
of the way it was not easy for Joe
Barroso I want to hear more about that
story about how he did with the
adversity at Ohio State and how he
turned that into the motivation that has
propelled him to where he is also he
reached out to Peyton Manning which
shows that he's smart he's doing his
homework he's getting advice he's
getting information he's not he's not
trapped by that arrogance of youth that
makes you think you have all the answers
and no one else who's been there before
can help you through it and Peyton
Manning had this to say about Joe burrow
reaching out I told him Joe when you're
the first pick in the NFL Draft you're
going to a team that has really earned
the first pick in the NFL Draft they
were going to be some holes there there
was a reason the Colts were picking
number one that year there's a reason
that bengals are picking number one this
year I will say this though Peyton
Manning walked into a team that had
Marvin Harrison and Marshall Faulk for
crying out loud so the deck was slightly
better stacked although the Bengals have
Joe Mixon and AJ Green I'll take Marvin
head right Marshall Faulk / AJ Green and
Joe Mixon Cris yes I mean me too but you
know AJ Green and Joe mix that's not a
bad second you know and you know I do I
think it's you know curious that Joe
girl
you know cause Peyton Manning I mean yes
that's the smart thing to do we see
nothing but really smart and perfection
and professionalism from Joe borough
since he's taken over as the LSU
quarterback and ever since he got
thrusted in the spotlight is the best
college player in football last year and
Mike you know I said it you know the guy
that he really reminds me of is Peyton
Manning
you know his style of play the way he
processes defenses how quickly he can go
through reads and flip the side of the
field and then read it diagnosed that
side of the field and make another you
know proper decision and accurate throw
of the football it's all just top-notch
let alone like those plays Mike you see
there he's got the little backyard feel
to him
Oh scrambled to the right 40-yard bomb
on the run right on the money I mean to
me he really has a similar style the
Manning he's just a new-age version a
little more athletic than Peyton maybe
not quite as big but extremely act
accurate extremely smart his arm is real
good it's not gonna wow you like Brett
Favre or Elway or Rodgers but it's
really good and man I just I would be
shocked Cincinnati's taking him number
one we can just move on to pick we
really can move on to pick number three
because Washington is taking chase young
they better make that quick on Thursday
night meanwhile for those of you keeping
score at home when it comes to Chris
Simms versus the English language
thrusted is an accepted past
henceforth rust although it is rarely
used in most cases rust in the past
tense of thrust not thrown but you're
okay on this one say well just in case
just in case if anybody thinks I
actually give a damn whether I really
they said they should check themselves
because I don't give a damn all right
the Denver Broncos are generating some
steam and some buzz Chris that they may
try to get into the top 10 to get a guy
that didn't make your top 5 receiver
list Jerry Judy what in the world is
John Elway see and Jerry Judy that you
don't well there's a lot of people that
see a lot of good and Jerry Judy I get
it I like Jerry Judy I just don't think
he's one of the top five talents in this
year's draft
I don't now this is a guy that yeah I
you know my friends people I talk to
around the NFL it's a little all over
the place some people really love Jerry
judy others that I know and trust don't
think he's a top three or top five
receiver in this draft it's gonna be a
little bit of the you know beauty in the
eye and beholder and like I said Mike
Judy is a phenomenal route runner
phenomenal and if he goes to an offense
that really prioritizes round running he
can thrive there's no doubt about it you
know if he went to an offense like the
Seattle Seahawks where they only run
about three or four patterns and it's
just like go straight and Russell hit
you he's not gonna thrive there cuz he's
not physically freaky enough to just win
one-on-one matchups and do that all the
time I really like the kid I think he
can have a great career it's a one thing
I hate about the draft cuz I don't want
to talk negatively about the kid but
I'll say this one thing Mike you know I
you know one I would think the Oakland
Raiders and you got to worry about the
New York Jets made liking Jerry Judy
right so Denver's probably worried about
one of those two teams and you know I
guess the other thing is I just find it
curious that this has been floated out
there you know this is the time of the
year why don't trust anything I hear
right off the bat because I just think
there's probably another rhyme or reason
to why Denver or somebody has floated
this rumor out there and I just haven't
figured that out yet quite yet and you
know when it comes to the receivers
Peter King and I were talking about this
on the show Friday
one of the key ingredients to potential
greatness could be could be the Michael
Thomas dynamic where you end up being
the last of the five top receivers taken
or not one of the top five you slide
into the second round look at what that
did to Michael Thomas the chip on the
shoulder that he gave him and when
you're taken in round one sometimes
sometimes there's and it's probably more
often than sometimes I think it's a
fairly common dynamic there's an
entitlement there's a complacency if
you're a first round pick there's a
sense that you've arrived when you
haven't done jack squat at the NFL level
whereas if you're passed over and you
have that list of names I mean how tom
brady still is obsessed about all the
guys that were taken in front of him at
the quarterback position 20 years ago so
maybe it would be good for Jerry Judy or
any of these guys whoever ends up not
being taken in round one at the receiver
position sliding into round two that may
light a fire that will make the guy
better than he would have been if he
would have been the first receiver taken
well III don't disagree with you there
yeah it's that's the human element of
this and you know a guy like Jerry Judy
if he did slip or fall or any of these
top receivers yeah they're gonna use
them as fuel for the future definitely
you know and to your big point Mike I
think more than anything is you know
just fit how you fit with the football
team is crucial
you know Michael Thomas would not be
Michael Thomas if he was on a bunch of
other teams in football he got to a
place where yes is a good quarterback
but there was a coach that really
understood how to really expose all the
great things he has to bring to a
football team and put him in positions
to succeed all the time so that's part
of it too and again I like Jerry Judy I
certainly do you know I could see my man
John Gurdon at pic 12
liking a guy like Jerry Judy cuz he does
value route running that way and he has
a lot of plays in his offense where the
the first read will have to run some
intricate detailed routes to get open
and and Judy it is that type of guy so
you know again I like Jerry Judy I just
don't think he's like a super freak
talented oh we can line you up with over
here and you
just gonna beat the top corner in
football play after play after play know
that was my concern I think it has to be
a little bit about a fit to me my top
five receivers you can put them on any
team and they're gonna fit and make it
happen and that's why he's not there but
nonetheless a really good football
player and as to that michael thomas
dynamic if you don't believe in that
then congratulations you're the one
sports fan in the country who watched
none of the Michael Jordan documentary
last night because it's obvious Jordans
ultimate greatness was fueled by every
actual and perceived slight that ever
landed his way throughout the course of
his life from the moment he was born all
right Dave Kellerman from the moment
he's been a GM in seven prior drafts
five at the Panthers two with the Giants
has never traded down never ever traded
down in any round he says he will
seriously entertain the possibility of
trading down from the fourth spot
yeah okay do you think I'm okay I fought
it I made it I got on the other side and
you made sure that I had a moment there
where I thought it needed the COFF and I
I managed through you know my skills and
experience and I've been there and done
that before I'll fight through it and
then thank you for pointing it out to
everyone yes I had to fight through a
coffin I had to do it again so what do
you think the Giants are gonna do do you
think they'll trade down and does it
make sense to trade down I think it does
because if you're the Giants you got
multiple holes to fill trade down get
more lottery tickets and hope to fill
those holes agreed I mean I would hope
they'd trade down to now they don't want
to trade to far I wouldn't want to do
that because you know I they do have a
tackle need to fill right that that's
the big thing and I would look at the
Giants at four and you know just through
my own evaluations on the offensive line
hey the kid from Alabama with bills
backed in you know the kid from Georgia
Thomas you know you look at all those
three I don't know if you can go wrong
with any of the three so if you're
sitting there on your board and all
three of them have a very close grade
you know you go okay let me trade down a
few spots I can get a few extra picks
and still get one of the three guys I
really like you'd go down too far of
course you're gonna miss out but I think
it makes a lot of sense for the Giants
to be looking back
you know in the trade back market but I
also would be careful there don't go too
far they need an offensive tackle badly
and I would expect that they stay at
four that's who they end up drafting
Mike and the Lions at three and the
Giants at four are the team's to watch
if someone wants to leapfrog the
Dolphins to get Justin Herbert or two
atong of I lower right and and right now
I think the prevailing view is Herbert
goes first but who the hell knows but
those are the two spots three and four
if you're the Chargers at six the
Panthers at seven you want to get in
front of the Dolphins at five then that
may be the trade and also don't rule out
the Dolphins being the one to prevent
getting leapfrog by doing the deal even
if it's a flip-flop with the Giants from
four to five if you know if the Giants
have a deal in place with the Panthers
of the Chargers the Dolphins swoop in
and they make them an offer they can't
refuse and the Giants slide back one
spot they get something extra and they
still get the guy they would have taken
at number four Chris so I agree with you
they still need to come out of this with
a mauler at tackle and it could be
Jedrek wills from Alabama they need a
top guy there but they have other needs
they need to fill as well as they try to
make that team competitive and put
talent around there they're great guys
all right we'll get Chris back here in a
moment his offensive line draft rankings
will be available later today on a
Monday edition of the unbuttoned podcast
Makai Becton of Louisville had a drug
test reportedly flagged at the Scouting
Combine I wrote about this over the
weekend I don't like that this gets out
it shouldn't get out especially now that
the NFL has relaxed the substance abuse
policy a positive at the Scouting
Combine is meaningless you go into stage
one for 60 days and if you don't have
any other incidents in the next 60 days
you come out of stage one and here's the
thing you can test positive an
indefinite number of times now you're
eventually going to face some
significant fines but you're never going
to be suspended the point is this is
something that the NFL needs to keep a
better handle on when it comes to
maintaining secrecy and privacy and
confidentiality and I always get even a
little more anxious about it
when the reports of these positive drug
tests from the Scouting Combine
originate with the media platforms that
are owned and operated by the NFL in a
roundabout way not in a roundabout way
in a very direct way they are violating
their own confidentiality policies by
putting out there on their own platforms
the fact that these guys are testing
positive at the Scouting Combine so look
I don't think it matters because I've
been told for years that most teams if
not all teams care about marijuana use
only because it can eventually cause you
to not be able to play and at some point
you have to make the choice do you love
football more than you love marijuana
under the new substance abuse policy if
you're not already suspended you're not
getting suspended for positive drug
tests now you can get suspended for
failing to comply with your treatment
program you can get suspended for other
irregularities that relate to the
testing process but you can keep testing
positive and never get suspended so I
think that's gonna make teams care even
less about guys who may have failed a
drug test at the Scouting Combine
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports